[Music]
right now for the Fujita 100 so about 30
minutes we is gonna go up there and
recreate a stunt that Houdini did a
hundred years ago to the gate
but first des is here
[Music]
takes Awards I'm honored to be here
today we're all here to see lead to
roasting do this when our first order of
business is to watch a video that Lee
has prepared on the big screen
what if you had the chance to not only
touch history
but creating
[Music]
four years ago I found an old
of Harry Houdini
the straight chest high above
it's work
[Applause]
[Music]
I love thank you so much at the bottom
of my heart I will always be a
Pittsburgh face always always always
follow your dreams
but today thank you so very much for
believing in mine there was a moment
[Music]
okay guys I'm with what Halloween what
just happened oh my god that was
incredible
straitjacket escape 90 feet above
streets of Pittsburgh today in front of
a couple thousand people he said that
you've been preparing this for about
like four and a half years anything what
actually goes into preparing comes a
giant jigsaw puzzle figure out all the
things that would go into creating this
and making this happen today
after seeing the image four and a half
years ago in a book and realizing that
there he did his stunts in Pittsburgh on
November 6 at the corner of wooden
Liberty I knew it was I was destined it
was opportunity become my next journey
so recreated today all the moving pieces
for my safety team the crane the crane
operator all the press
everyone Lux creative who helped put all
this together Lama cranes all the
sponsors that came out all everybody all
the Pittsburghers that just you know
yeah hanging out with Sally Wiggin Sally
would say yeah Sally
I mean Franco Harris look in credit he
could have called me Donny iris here I
mean it was the best congratulations
[Music]